all right everybody welcome to another
League of Legends plus ask me anything
business advice with my co-host Rishi
Cup TV welcome board
Rishi thanks so much Evan hi believe
Nation hi everyone we're we're in
backtack days this is
serious I'm loving it I hope you're
loving it because I'm loving it it's
getting serious it's getting
serious yesterday was all about raising
capital and uh it turned up a little bit
actually I I had to go nap after that
session
yesterday seriously cuz I had a whole
day of uh Hangouts and interviews and
calls and oh man I need I need to break
I need a break after my 4our sleep so it
was good it was good it was a fun day
yesterday it was fun and I caught uh
some of those Hangouts they were on fire
nice all right well I'm making sure this
is
online
it says I'm streaming but it's showing
offline on
Twitch I'm gonna load up a
game I do see you because you are live
on my end nice all right let's load up a
game see if we can get our Teemo jungle
on and
uh what's this one oh oh this is New Q
is fast if you go support well that's no
surprise
all right let's hit up our first
question what do we
got let's do it our first question comes
from Victoria and she is trying to break
into the curve modeling
industry and she also would really like
to start her own business in particular
her own lipstick line or her own Li
lipstick range and she was wondering if
you have any advice or information how
she could do this she wants to start a
progr
line her yep she wants to get into the
curve modeling
industry and then from she also wants to
start her own litic what what was the
first one what model
industry curve modeling curve modeling
okay yeah so curve modeling from what I
understand is I mean I don't know if
they call it more plus-sized model but
right right right right okay that's
cool all right so uh the first thing
that came to mind for you Victoria is
start a YouTube
channel um because it it would just be
so fun especially since you're in the
beginning of your journey uh and there's
going to be so many people out there who
probably have a similar desire and would
be really inspired to see your journey
and your process so even from starting a
video that says hey I don't know what
I'm doing but this is what my dream and
my goals are and and um that obviously
then is a great way to
start um a a brand and even if you don't
know that right off the bat you're
starting to get people familiar with you
and with modeling and with makeup and
one of my favorite makeup YouTubers
actually uh from just their own YouTube
channel and working really hard and and
making amazing videos you know they
started their own uh I think they have
their own brush he he has his own line
of brushes now cosmetic brushes and I
don't know if he has lipstick but
um I just think that's a great place to
start um and then I'd also in the
meantime I would look for someone to to
work with or Mentor me in that in that
uh maybe you know you know another
person who's started their own rush or
their own lipstick or their own eyes
Shadow you know get with someone who's
done it
before what do you think
Evan um I like it I I'm
thinking I'm wondering just how
distracted is going to be to try to
create two products at the same
time um I got to ban a champion who am I
going to ban I'm gonna ban
y
um so you think between going trying to
break into the curving modeling industry
and also starting our lipstick range
might be too much at once
my My worry is that it's just going to
take up yeah it's going to be it's going
to be too much to do all at once and
you'll just end up being mediocre or
both instead of dominating one thing
um I would try to figure out which one
I'm most passionate about and go in on
that once you have a name whether it's
uh being a model having a YouTube
channel like reesi suggested it's way
easier to create product around it
people will buy your lipstick because of
who you are because of the fan base that
you've built up and so from a from a
practical point of view that one makes
the most sense of starting with the the
modeling the curve modeling getting the
channel up getting your name out there
becoming a brand that people recognize a
name that when people see they know who
it is uh having a fan base and then
creating product that you love um around
lipstick or whatever the next thing is
but you know the practical thing is not
always the best thing to do like if the
lipstick is what is what you love and
that's that's your biggest passion then
you could do that and you could be in
the lipstick commercials and you can
model for you know your lipstick ads and
if you're doing website you know your
face is on there um but I I think I
think for now I would pick one and have
the other one take a back seat uh
doesn't mean you're not thinking about
it you're not looking for opportunities
but um
take a back seat so you can focus on
having the success that you're after if
you're going for the modeling I agree I
think getting your name out there having
a YouTube channel uh doing a bunch of
free work you know like getting on
Craigslist and seeing what what people
are needing models for for videos for
photo shoots student projects just
building up your portfolio
and one opportunity leads to another
leads to another I mean I found my uh
video guy who comes in and and shoots me
every Wednesday for my channel on
Craigslist um and now we've now we've
worked I don't know for over a year
together um I auditioned a couple people
and he was the one I likeed the best and
and we've been working together for a
while so you need to build up your
portfolio you need to be able to see the
stuff that that you've done and work on
as many projects as possible and start
meeting people in the industry and so
that's an easy way just to get started
and and you know expect not to get paid
at the start um kind of the process just
to build your name if you're doing the
lipstick launch I'd be looking
at like what's different about your
lipstick what's is it the ingredients is
the process is The Branding is it the
messaging right if it's the ingredients
then like you might have to create your
own lipstick at home and figure it out
uh and then go and get it manufactured
if it's just a m meing and The Branding
you might be able to license or buy
existing lipstick lines um and just
package it and label it with your own
messaging so depending on what the
intent of certain that lipstick line is
there's a couple different options to go
with
um but I would definitely try to think
about what your message is if you're
going with the the lipstick line uh how
the marketing is going to be different
than the ones that are already out there
how you want women to feel when they're
putting on your lipstick and instead of
other people's lipstick uh cuz there's
so many lipsticks out there that you
need to be able to differentiate
yourself
yeah absolutely a lipstick with a
message all right so next question comes
from ask and I hope I'm saying that name
right ask I'm sorry if I'm
not so ask this is a a little bit more
of an in-depth question Evan uh sent you
a 14
page document called Epic stepbystep
guide to lower price by
lead and so he basically is making a
guide for his customers and wanted to
get your feedback in regards to this
document um and he's got some bullet
points of questions do you want me to
ask you those specific
questions
uh sure let's let's hear it okay the
first question is um in pertains to
making this
better does he add more datadriven
arguments or
reasoning uh does he I know that for our
listeners this is a little bit out of
context but because you guys can't see
the document but the question
is well this is probably a good time too
to say that those of you guys who are
asking you know questions to Evan who is
I know gosh I
mean jam-packed all the all day every
day um changing the world
um if you want to get your questions
answered and you know that someone is
got a lot of things going on maybe
sending an email with a very large
document to to get feedback isn't the
best approach how many questions did
were
there well there were five
questions okay four questions and I
guess since you don't have the document
I don't know if there I guess we you you
let me know how you want answer this
question then the third question
is he has a analogy in the document that
he wanted feedback on and then he had a
question about the
headlines
okay what do you think so I guess what I
would what I would just my feedback
probably for ask is this is a great
lesson I think for how to be how to
really leverage or get the most out of
getting feedback from people who
are
um who are who you're aspiring to you
know be or get feedback from and
realizing that most of the time
people may have literally only 10
seconds to glance at an email and so the
likelihood actually we were talking
about this yesterday or Tuesday Ian when
one of the people uh one of the
questions was about trying to get
Oprah's
attention and so realizing that people
who are super super super world changer
busy people if you send them something
and you want feedback on it the
likelihood is that maybe you'll get
a little bit of time for them to check
out your email or your call so I would
just give feedback more specifically to
ask about when you uh want feedback from
someone who's super busy super on
purpose try to figure out a way to make
it really quick and easy for that person
um to give you the feedback that you
need because now I'm not speaking for
you Evan but I if I got a 14 page
document and I was super super busy I
don't know that I'd be able to even open
it
up so that's my kind of tough love re
re's dishing it out's dishing it out
today uh so update on the game here I'm
playing himer mid so it's not my usual
character but uh we'll see how it goes
uh and I just want I just want to say
too that I've done that I've done that
before like I've made the assumption
that someone has all the Time in the
World to like he my problems right and
the reality is is everybody's trying to
do stuff so um it's not that people
don't care but it's just we've got to
realize that um we have to be a little
bit realistic especially with people who
are really super uh on purpose like I
know you
are yeah and and I agree it's kind of
some tough love um and I want to give
you an example maybe in looking at um
when I was getting getting Gary
vaynerchuk to endorse my book and how
that kind of came
about
uh I first met Gary and this might be a
bit of a long story but hopefully it
it's it's helpful uh I first met Gary
when I was making a line of entrepreneur
trading cards back in 2010 and I asked
him to recommend who his favorite famous
entrepreneur was so I could add that to
his own card
and I didn't connect with him for
another couple years I was really at the
time I wasn't like a huge fan just
looking at just looking at uh famous
entrepreneurs and wanted to make this
line of cards and he was one of 30
people that were part of a the blog
series I wanted to then as I learned
more about him like maybe four years
later get more involved you know help
him out ask him some questions um get on
his show as that came about
and every time IAT emailed him it it
never it didn't lead anywhere I didn't
get a I didn't get a response
uh and the key thing there that really
helped me
was I did things differently so the next
thing I did with Gary was I made a a
thank you Gary video where I connected
with 50 of his fans who made a video
saying thank you for all the work that
he had done now to get 50 people to make
a video it means I had to contact
hundreds of
people right like 50 people actually
responded with the video so that's a lot
of work right you know it's it's a lot
of back and forth it was a insane amount
of
effort uh but it got his
attention it got noticed he cared right
because nobody else put in that kind of
work to reach
him wow
uh and then I wrote to him to say some
questions for his show to try to get on
that kind of stuff and I still didn't uh
I didn't get a response on that but he
did email me a thank you for for the
making the thank you video uh so I had
his email so that was a good
start
um what happened next was I made the top
10 rules of for success of him he was
trying to promote his book at the time
it was a good exposure for
him and that worked out really well and
again he wrote back and said thank you
and it helped give him some exposure for
the
book and then I wanted to have him on my
show and we did an interview we ended up
doing an interview a while ago maybe a
month ago I wanted to have him on my
channel to talk about what he was up to
with the book do an interview I didn't
respond and then I saw an email a video
one of his videos talking about how he
likes super short emails and he likes
doing business just in the subject line
so I wrote him a an email just in a
subject line saying hey love to have you
on the show got 300,000 Subs let's do it
let's promote your book and he wrote
back and he said
yes and
so think about the amount of work that
went into that if like if there somebody
who you want to get on their radar
they're not going to read a 14-page
document and then answer questions for
you right unless unless you've done
something insanely crazy to help them
unless they know you from somewhere it's
not something that most people are going
to do right and Gary you know I gave a
lot of love to Gary and it took a long
time to get any kind of impact and reach
there but I also wasn't offended I also
didn't feel like you know this guy owes
it to me you know I did this for him he
better respond we better you know he
better do this I recognize that he's a
busy guy he's got a lot going on and I
just put it on me to I need to stand out
more I need to do better so one if you
if you are reaching out to
people you you know I make an effort I
think more than most to try to respond
to questions and be engaged uh most
people
don't respond to their comments respond
to questions at all so you might have an
easier time getting a hold of me but
still I'm not going to read a 14-page
document and then answer five questions
right and and hopefully that doesn't you
know upset you
but it's
uh it's
important it's important I'm in the
middle of a fight I got a
kill and I died you actually look you
actually oh wow I was just about to say
you look like you're doing exceptionally
well today yeah I died I died it was
okay I was doing I was doing well and
then I anyway I I got one kill and I
died too so it's it's okay um so so
lessons learned from that from that
story one is add more value right if you
want to get on somebody's radar add more
value right I should look at their email
and say oh it's an email from this guy I
have to open it right like if REI sent
me an email asking me to look at a
14-page document I would cuz cuz reishi
added a lot of value right so if you're
trying to reach out to somebody add more
value make your name recognizable if if
they see your name it should be
something that is they know who you are
right and and maybe maybe you feel like
I should know who you are I don't know
but I don't so you got to add more
value
um
second make sure that you are keeping
your ask
easy right like if you just asked me one
question I probably would
have I got a kill nice if you ask me one
question I probably would have just
answered
it uh without reading the 14-page
document I probably would have just
answered it to try to help but because
you made it so hard to answer you you're
asking for too much time then I
can't so one add more value two keep
your ask
easy and that'll improve the chances now
let's try to help him out with one of
the with one of the questions it's it's
a 14 page document that is what's the
what's the purpose of
it so it's a It's called The Epic step
by the Epic stepbystep guide to lower
price by
lead so um you know with I guess without
having the document in front of you are
there there's some maybe essential
elements that you feel are really
important to include in a guide for your
customers I mean we could kind of make
it uh general for because you know
people are always wanting to improve
their their
uh their guides or whatever it is that
they're providing for their customers
it's like a free bonus PDF download kind
of thing
forom got it okay so whether you useing
it for like your newsletter list or
you're you know just having it as
something on your website right uh
General things I would suggest one most
importantly make it something that
you're proud
of make it something that if
you uh oh I'm going to
die I died very sad make it something
that you're proud of like what are the
things that that are really important
like it's not just a sales document but
there's a lot of value in there what are
the some of the common things that
customers are asking you that that you
see as problem that is really different
about your business don't just throw
together a bunch of things that aren't
really going to add a ton of value make
it again something that you you are
massively proud of like this is going to
be this is going to help a lot of people
then you may be wrong like it may not
help it may not be super valuable but at
least you think it is um so that would
be of all the
things like whether you add more data
whether you add more you know
testimonial or stories or facts and
figures or whatever it is it doesn't
really matter there's different kinds of
styles that people like some people love
the graphs in the stores people love the
pictures uh honestly your
style if you if you write and create in
your style you'll attract customers that
appreciate that style and feel the same
way just make sure that it's something
that you love and you're proud of most
important thing with with the document
that you're creating not just for
marketing purposes but this is a ton of
value in
it that's awesome yeah definitely
something that will will really catch
people's attention I mean there's so
much so much already out there that you
really have to I think too it comes back
to a little bit of that one word and
being able to put that in anything right
like having because I see anything that
you put out EV it's always feel got to
focus it's purpose in some way yeah I
don't know if that if that helps but um
ask if you're at all all familiar with
uh the book that is in pre-launch right
now Evan's book uh one word just talks
about being really uh well I'm not going
to say what it talks about because you
should buy it but um I think the I think
the most important thing is just like
really have a clear focus on what your
what you feel
um is your your purpose and vision in
the midst of of your business because I
think that you can Infuse that into
anything whether it's a guide or
a um you know any freebie that you're
offering your customers it just kind of
brings it all together and gives it a
focus
so thanks for the question
ask next question are you ready for it
hit me
up next question it comes from Damian
and Daman says as you know Evan I'm a
big fan of your work I was wondering if
I could request
from entrepreneurs for the top 10 rules
for
success and well I think that's a pretty
common question and people are always
making uh
requests so um Evan have you changed how
people make requests or people still
just make requests in the comments of
their videos yeah the the best way is is
uh in the
video uh my team picks it up so what
happens with you know I want I want
every comment that that we put out sorry
every comment that gets put up on the
video to be uh to get a response feel
people are spending their time leaving
the comments we owe owe it to them to
give a response
um and so I do a lot of them but also I
want I want to you know make sure that
the ones that I'm doing are of value and
you know if I had to spend my time on
some comments that it's it's basically
paying off right so the request ones are
not you know the most fantastic use of
my time uh but my team does pick it up
so the easiest way to to get a request
is just leave a comment on the video my
team picks it up and uh we're trying to
pick the ones that are more requested
that are more popular uh that lots of
people have asked for uh we're trying to
do a better job of that before we just
go in order of the most the oldest one
but people keep asking for the same ones
over and over again so that okay we owe
it to them to give them uh if like 100
people are asking for the same one we
want to try to offer that for
them but yeah easiest way is just leave
a comment on the video tell me what you
want my team will pick it up the
questions come to me and uh that's it
that's how we
pick and you might be surprised when you
ask for a
request and there's already a video made
so I've seen that happen where people
ask for they request a person in the
video has actually already made oh tons
tons like it it's also it's a it almost
comes back to the last question about
the 14 page document like respecting the
time you know we're making these videos
it's free for
you just do a search to see if it's
already there or not right chances are
we may have already made it a lot of
them lot of them we have already done
and it just boggles my mind that people
aren't
uh searching
first to see like one for your own
time like you really want that just type
in that person's name we're probably
going to show up for top
10 right I know pretty much it was funny
my top 10 came up and I was excited I
was like Yay at the end he's going to
give me a shout out and then it was
someone else who had made the request
before
the sadness sadness yeah so people get
so upset about that too they're like I
requested this how could you put someone
else's name well they requested it like
three months before you
did yeah I thought I was all unique but
I guess not
okay
um by the way I don't know if you saw J
rise had had uh earlier on tried to
enter your game but I don't know if you
got that message
oh
no okay all right good to know
um he's I think he's started his own
game at this point so okay that's fine
he usually comes over on a Friday so we
would do it together but he's his
parents were in town
so okay so the next question comes from
Tony and Tony says Evan I need your
input on a product that I'm trying at
this moment it's called Forever Living
it's
organic I think he wants to say aloe
vera product and I want to make it
really
different and this thing actually has a
real benefit how can I try to Broad
broadcast to
all what about its benefits he's tried
through charity health awareness but
it's still not really working do you
have any
advice got it okay so it we we actually
had spoken to um Tony we had spoken to
someone else who was doing something
that was very natural
um product that I had I think it had a
lot of like healing benefits and similar
stor she was kind of struggling to uh
get traction for it and so you may want
to check out some of the earlier League
of leg Legends videos I think it might
have been one or two episode one or
two um so the first question about um
how can you broadcast it my question
would be to you have you started a
YouTube channel um that's that's one way
to absolutely start broadcasting right
away to a global audience
about uh your
product and
um you know I think there just when I
think about like healthy aloe products I
mean I don't know so for me personally
I'm just going to
say that alone doesn't tell me enough to
be really excited about it
um so I think this go also goes back to
the previous question of uh we were
talking to the makeup the the girl who
wanted to do the lipstick it's like how
are you going to differentiate this
organic product from every other one
that's out there because there's
tons and
um I believe that it probably does have
a real realistic benefit but I I would
need more to be really excited about
buying it and I don't know if that strs
through education as well if you were
broadcasting on YouTube maybe you could
offer some online classes about how to
use the product and why it's super
beneficial and get people start getting
people involved and educated about why
it's a benefit but even beyond that I
still think um you've got to
differentiate it in a way that will
really stand out to
people so it didn't say what the product
does right just as an aloe vera product
has a lot of benefits that's it
exactly yeah uh agreed you know I think
there's a lot of people trying to sell
stuff and uh you'll need to do a better
job like even even thinking about this
right like you have an opportunity here
to ask a question get some promotion get
people to know a little bit about what
you're doing and REI and I are both
confused as to what you're actually
selling which which isn't great right
like you want
to add value and explain what it is that
you're
doing uh in every interaction like it
should be clear what your product is so
that it's easy for us to talk about and
share it um that being said you know the
easiest way to to grow a business and
get more sales is through alliances so
who can you partner up with who already
has your target market um I think you'll
I think I think there's an opportunity
to create a YouTube channel like rishi's
idea I think you'll get more short-term
results
by uh collaborating with people who
already have a YouTube audience because
it'll take you some time to build up
your own channel but if you collaborate
with people who already have a channel
who already have an audience where there
there is an interest already they're
they're talking about health related
stuff um then that's that's a much
faster way to be able to build up and
sell where longer term play is to have
your own channel because you know as
reishi knows too creating your own
YouTube channel takes time to build
doesn't just happen overnight um so I'd
be thinking alliances I'd be thinking
influencers people who are big on
YouTube Twitter Facebook Instagram Etc
Snapchat uh as well
as other other kinds of alliances like
retail distribution you know you don't
need to do um you don't need to only
think online you can go more traditional
as well just think about who is already
selling to your target audience and how
can you make some kind of alliance with
them so that they'll want to sell your
product yeah awesome
shout out to zo who just who just popped
into the chat what up Z welcome aboard
man he was in for he was in he he was in
for most of the Hangouts yesterday too
and then he was late he was late to the
third one and he was getting shout outs
he's like Z where are you people wanted
to know where Z was so he's got he's
he's got that level of recognition
already yep I love it hardcore believe
Nation hardcore
yep all right so the next question comes
from Patricia okay and P Patricia she
wants to ask you as a master YouTuber is
what she calls you uh could you please
answer one question I made a she made a
trailer
for uh like a video trailer for an
author and um so this client of hers she
was really embarrassed because basically
this trailer video that she made for
this author client was
removed and she was freaking out so
embarrassed and but she says YouTube is
not explaining why why this video got
removed
so she's wondering about is it possible
that because she linked to Amazon at the
end of a
video you know is this is this why she
was infringing or somehow
maybe you know not following the rules
of
YouTube I don't know about an Amazon
link I don't think that should be a
reason why your video would be
removed um there's tons of videos on
YouTube
about uh things that get you flagged
things that get you you know and it's
all usually copyright infringement so I
for me I would ask about like music did
you use music and the video that um you
didn't have the rights to use but Amazon
links Evan do you know anything about
Amazon link so so first off YouTube
always says why they remove a video uh
you always get a notification so if if
it's not your account if your author's
account then just log into to those I
wish I had it open now log into the
channel and click on channel like if you
go to my videos the backend the author
dashboard and click on channel it'll
show you uh if you have any strikes uh
and if you look at the video itself on
the video manager it'll show
you why it got blocked or removed it
won't it won't be like YouTube won't
delete a
video so if it's gone then then whoever
owns the
account deleted it and and maybe they're
lying to you uh to be honest they won't
delete a they'll never delete a video
even if they block it they'll block it
you might get stried you might get muted
uh you might get taken down in certain
countries but the video will still be in
your video
manager so the only way to actually take
it out of video manager is to delete it
yourself so the author must have deleted
it somehow um well I I she I think maybe
maybe it is in the video manager but I'm
wondering did they just like I I've seen
muted videos but I don't know you know
they take down videos as well don't they
and then they put a big this video was
removed because of copyright in fren or
whatever you're right they always tell
you so she should have known right so it
may be it may be it may be removed from
like public view but it's still in your
back end it's always in your back end
and so that holds a secret for you to
figure out what the problem was and they
always say what the problem was like
I've had videos uh that that were
blocked because we used the song I I had
a I had a vacation video where I was
singing Let It Go and it got
blocked because I was singing Let It
Go and you know Disney I guess dude that
song they're not gonna let you get
anything on that nothing nothing I mean
my version wasn't that great either
but um anyway that aside like Amazon
links are fine there's a there's a c so
there's a certain number of uh of
trusted author Authority links that they
allow you to link
from uh and link to within a video uh
they do it now through their interactive
card so there's a variety of those
videos that you are allowed to
link um uh oh am I GNA die am I gonna
die am I gonna die no I'm not GNA die so
yes so Amazon is one of the one of the
authority ones that that that's okay
yeah Amazon should be fine there's a few
like there's some affiliate sites
there's some other ones that are that
are totally cool that they approve if
you're putting stuff in the description
then then you're fine uh you can put
whatever you want in the description
there's nothing wrong with promotional
videos like YouTube won't take down a
video because you're promoting a book
there's nothing wrong with it
so uh the secret lies really in your
author backend in your YouTube backend
sorry to look at it and see why uh why
they're giving you a why they took it
down
that's it okay that's
good good luck with that Patricia yeah
um all right so next question is Carl he
said I watched one of your YouTube
videos and what I was looking
for is how do you sell only an
idea okay so he wants to he wants to
know how can you sell an idea
all right so um interesting question um
that is I feel like I would need more
more context but
um is this idea a product is this idea a
service is this idea literally
just uh something that you can't
actually execute on and
practically do in action um
Evan have you had this question before
what do you what do you think about it
well okay so like you got to understand
that the idea is not enough most of the
time uh you know I when I was in ADV
Venture Capital business we never sign
non-disclosure agreements which
basically says like I won't talk about
it um because we got so many people
pitching the same idea at the same time
like a slightly different execution but
one person's business plan was not
really that different than somebody
else's so it comes down to the team
behind the idea so the only really way
to sell an idea is if you can get it
patented you get a patent that's
basically what it is I have an idea for
something and now I have this protection
and I'm going to sell it it's really the
only way
because like say you have an idea for
like a lot of people say hey I have an
idea for Microsoft to be way better well
like so do I I've got a million ideas
for Microsoft to get better doesn't mean
they're going to pay me for it the way
to the way to get paid for it is like if
you go and talk to Microsoft and they
actually like the idea what do you think
they're going to do they're just going
to take it right why do they need you
you already give the idea yeah so the
only way to do it is if your idea is
protected right like they have to pay
you for it because if they do it on
their own oops whoa don't die don't die
I'm fine okay if they do it on their own
um and try you can sue
them so the only real way to get an idea
and just sell that alone without any
kind of execution without you doing any
of the work like if the value ad is just
in that initial idea and you add no more
value on top of it afterwards then you
need to get the
patent
okay
great
that was easy enough let's move on to
the next question yeah um Lindsay she
says how do oh how do you prepare for
finding potential Angel
Investors so she is this is a longer
question as well so we can get into more
of the detail of it um but she's in the
she's in the limousine
industry she wants to transition out of
that industry to be a full-time Web
Master
Web
Master a Web Master Okay of the
dot uh says the
dot I don't know what that means and Li
and limo directory the dot and limo
directory
site so I think she has multiple
websites that
are in the limousine
industry and anyway she's been really
struggling because basically Bally
Uber of uber is is leading to I guess
the limousine industry demise sure so
she's looking for angel investor here in
Melbourne and um so she gave a list of
requirements or basically things that
she specifically needs from an angel
investor
and pretty much just wanted to know from
you what do you what do you think do we
know you want to go through each
question what's the money
for um that's what she lists the
different things that she's going to
need so she's looking for about 35 to
40,000 and she needs a media campaign TV
and radio she wants to create an app she
wants to hire two people for two months
to help create approximately 1,200
listings
and so then she has three questions
followup questions from
there you want me to continue or you
want to start there
or uh I I mean I have enough to go on I
don't know if you have an answer
already well uh it looks at least this
is
actually maybe the first uh person that
has asked for looks like she has a very
a little bit more of a real clear plan
as to how she wants to be prepared if
she is going to go ask for an investor
um and
uh I guess I'm I'm trying to look at her
questions too so I can respond a little
bit according
to I would want to ask her is she super
super before she does all of
this knowing what she does know about
the industry
changing like I really want to ask her
like is this super what she's passionate
about like is this a good idea or is
this like your passion idea is this what
you really feel is I mean because it
does seem like it's going to be a little
bit of an uphill battle um and
so uh I would just want to make sure
that she feels very much like this is
absolutely where she wants to go all in
and you might know more right now about
how this how this industry is changing
Evan but I just I know
that I know that Uber in particular it's
like pretty much threatened a lot of the
uh other
companies and then I guess I would ask
uh before going be you know before an
investor I wonder how much of a margin
you would expect in this industry I mean
it's this kind of like the remember we
were talking about the grocery Market
industry and how like would would an
angel investor want is this what an
angel investor would want to invest
in
um those are just some questions I know
those aren't answers
but what do you
think uh I think you're gonna have a
really hard time getting an angel
investor for this I
think the market
is not where you want it to where it
where like where people want to see it
now they people don't want to invest in
apps too for like like they don't want
to pay your R&D right like if you want
to do an app great but they want to see
that you've built it and you're you're
you're growing and you need marketing
dollars not that I I want to build an
app but I need the money to do
it especially if you're in an industry
that's declining or that's suffering and
that's struggling nobody wants to take
that bet it's just too risky a bet
yeah that's the
challenge I don't think people would bet
on it so the way to do it is you got to
prove it like start smaller prove it
build up some momentum for it show that
it
works and then you can easily raise
money to
expand I'm still not 100% what the idea
is but if it's to watch a series of
websites like just
go out and do
it uh oh am i g to die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna
die I died very
sad um yeah I'm doing okay 94 and 12 but
my team is uh the team is throwing a
little bit here we'll
see um yeah do it like nobody's going to
invest money in something that
is like have you proven that before like
have you proven that you can get me
media exposure for something you want to
do a media campaign have you had success
with that before have you hired people
for two months before and gotten results
from it have you built an app before and
gotten results from it right if you
haven't then you have to go out and
prove it because otherwise like imagine
somebody came to you and wanted money
and said hey give me how much is it
$30,000 yeah 30 35 to 40 so give me
$40,000 I'm want to do a bunch of stuff
that I've never done before and I'm
pretty sure it's going to work out like
there's no way you would you wouldn't do
it you wouldn't give them the money it's
just too risky so you have to you have
to find the the path of least resistance
find the easiest way to get
started and just start and prove some
initial
results like if you've done it before if
you've had success then people will just
give you money because they bet on you
because you've done it before like if I
wanted to go raise money for something I
could do it off an idea because I've
done it before
right but if you haven't and it's a new
field for you it's for everybody not not
just not just the question but for
everybody who's kind of thinking the
same thing nobody's going to pay you to
learn you have to be able to figure it
out and they'll pay you to expand but
they don't want you making mistakes on
their
dollar
right my team is throwing hard
yeah it
does all
right but but hopefully like it helps
educate too and explains what needs to
be done in order to get to where she
wants to
go absolutely
absolutely I think to uh I think it's
always good like if you're going to ask
if you are going to jump into this
because you you know make sure you're
really really love it you know CU it
does sound like it's going
to when an industry is declining you
have to you have to be doing it because
you it's just compelling you you have to
you love it that much you know yeah and
there is a way to win and honestly like
if you're still really thinking about it
I went on a long explanation yesterday
in the video about how to raise Capital
with all the different options and what
they look for and all that so um I I
checked that out but honestly just
thinking about this situation I think
you have to narrow down to what you can
be really successful at and and go prove
it before you try to raise Capital
against
it he
great um next question comes
from
imone and imone says um she has this
she's always had a dream of being an
entrepreneur uh owning a Dano bus
transportation business so another
Transportation industry
um and she
basically hold on one second it's a
little hard to understand this
um okay so she's asking specifically
about if she goes into this
transportation business is it good to
start with partnering with someone got
it okay
and uh yeah I mean um I don't know if in
the in the beginning depending on how
much uh background she has in this
particular industry I mean I don't know
if she could
immediately start with Partnerships um
hearing from your experience Evan your
Partnerships always were formed because
you
were uh adding a ton I mean it was
mutually beneficial in terms ter of the
value that was going to be added from
the partnership so if she is in the
beginning stages of this industry um it
might
be important that she has a lot of value
to bring to it um but I would definitely
also start with uh getting to know
someone in this industry being really
getting really familiar with the with
the industry and
um and just doing it you know getting
maybe getting involved in in
another business that's doing exactly
what she wants to do so she can really
start to gain the knowledge of the
business feel like I might die yeah uh
so for me
Partnerships are interesting I've had
success with them um I've had some non
successes with them you know it's like
getting getting married that's what it
is people people just jump
into uh Partnerships because it looks
good on paper like oh well you're really
good at operations and I'm really good
at sales that's a perfect partnership
why don't we connect and then you get
into business and it slowly starts to
fall apart
um just like just like in a relationship
you want to you want to date before you
get getting married and it can be a
really great way like if you know that
you're locking skills and you really
want to do something and and you know
you want that accountability partner you
want to do something together with
somebody it can be fantastic but it has
to be the right person just like you
wouldn't just look up uh you know a
profile on a dating website and decide
to marry that person you know you'd want
to learn about them first and date them
and spend a little bit of time together
so
in theory it can be fantastic but what
you need to do is set up some test
projects first to do together something
start something on a trial see how well
you work together see if it's something
that really fits well together you're
really collaborating well together uh
and if you are then you can structure
something more more solid and long term
but to start I would say make sure
you're you're just really careful about
how you're going to be uh bringing on
the person um I'm going to
die oh I oh I I died I I killed three
but I died I killed three but I died um
dang it and and it's the same too it's
okay we we we're doing well we're gonna
I think we're going to win um it's the
same thing for bringing on from from
bringing on uh employees not to the same
level because a partner like if you have
a crappy business partner it sucks it
sucks to get out because they own a
chunk of your business um just like you
know if you're in a relationship when
you need to get divorced it sucks right
and hopefully you learn about yourself
enough so that the next time you do it
uh you can avoid the traps that you fell
into uh but when you're bringing on
people on your team as well you want to
make sure that they're people that don't
just share the skills that you need but
share the same values and coming back to
the idea of the one word what is it that
you stand for what's so important to you
and having somebody on your team and
somebody Who You're partnered with who
loves that who agrees with you who's the
exact same
um so yes it makes sense as a strategy
could be amazing for you just make sure
you're doing your research and uh don't
get into the bed with the wrong
person well it sounds like she does have
some experience too um it's a little
hard to for me to fully get this uh how
she's uh how she's wording it but um
let's say she decides just to go for it
on her own and she doesn't do the
partnership route um do you have any
like quick guidelines or tips as
to um you know how she could just get
started on her own because she sounds
like she she may not actually go the
partner route if she feels like she
could do it on her own in
beginning right so what what is what's
the
business it's a uh it's a Dano bus
transportation so um looks like it's a a
bus company right okay so I'd be looking
at what does she feel is missing like
what are the skills that she doesn't
have that that she needs and how else
can she find those skills if it's not
through a partnership okay right so like
what's holding you back from getting
started why can't you go out and do this
tomorrow maybe partnership is still the
right way to go all I'm saying is find
make sure you're doing it with the right
person um but what what are the skills
like what are you missing what do you
need to be able to get this thing off
the ground hey we won
yes yes
congrats
um yeah so like what's holding their
back from getting started how can you
start this in a small scale as possible
um what's preventing you from taking
that next step understanding that and
then breaking that down into the
simplest steps possible like maybe it's
well I need a bus wait how do we do here
I got
s+ I had 17 kills five deaths and 16
assists pretty solid let the game in CS
oh here's a thing that you said from
from Jr yeah okay I didn't see that
um yeah like say okay my the thing that
hold me back is I need a bus you know I
need I can't get a bus well do you have
to go out and buy a bus you know does it
can you lease a bus can you make a
partnership with somebody who already
has a bus that's not being used and give
them a cut of the sales that you make
like be resourceful it's not just about
the getting the the money it's about
trying to find ways to stretch what you
have so if you can't afford to get a bus
then find someone who has a bus and try
to make some kind of alliance like hey
your bus is just sitting there not being
used or or you don't want to get in the
business anymore how about I take it
over and give you a cut of the profits
that I make from it you know or if you
need help on the marketing side you know
can you go to your local University and
and say hey I'd love for you to help me
uh with your students as their project
for the semester help me market my new
bus transportation company like you got
to start thinking uh outside the box and
be resourceful because there's going to
be a million of these things that will
come up as an entrepreneur that you need
to uh address so the partnership bro
still be the best one just for you like
especially if you need that
accountability like I want to do this
with somebody I don't want to do it
alone uh just again make sure that
you're picking the right
person
cool cool how many more questions uh do
you want do you want me to ask so I know
well I think that's it over over ask you
oh yeah the game we won that's it I won
game is
over
okay um until next time I until next
time Evan thanks so much cool and uh
Rishi what's what's the latest on your
channel what's happening what are you
doing now what are you up
to ah well um you know I've I've been on
a little bit of a my schedule changed a
little bit I was at five days a week and
I've been doing one video a week for
right now now um but I've been super
missing it like every day I'm like I
want to put a video out today and talk
to my people um Rishi Cup TV is my
channel you uh reishi Cup TV where good
music good food and good talk intersect
although I'll just say this the good
food part is probably being transitioned
out for something way in my mind way
cooler
so um I'm excited about some changes on
the channel and
uh yeah just hoping to make some really
fun good content for everybody but I
like it and if you're missing it it's a
good
sign I am I really am I yesterday I I
almost did a Google Live Google Hangout
just to like chat with folks
because a lot of your answers were also
like you should do a YouTube channel so
you can tell there's YouTube on the
brain
there hey I really do Love YouTube it's
just super fun so excited to get back to
my five day a week
schedule very cool all right guys well
thank you for joining uh stay tuned for
the next episode not sure when it's
going to come out but we'll let you know
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and we'll see you
soon believe y'all bye